One particularly interesting thing about observables, and
observable arrays, is that they're actually functions.
If we hop over into the console here, I can verify that this page has
knockout by typing, ko, sure enough knockout is this object.
If I make a new observable array I can say, ko.observableArray.
And inside I'm going to pass it its initial array.
Sure enough, that returns our observable array.
Now I'm going to go ahead and make a variable, I'll call it foo.
And now we can call console.dir on foo.
Now before I run this,
I just want to point that this observable array here, foo, is a function.
I can validate that by typing just simply foo.
And sure enough, you can see that it's a function.
Now remember that in JavaScript functions are also objects.
And if we extrapolate from that,
we can infer that functions will also be able to have properties on them.
Let's show that by typing console.dir foo.
Sure enough if we open this up we can see all of this stuff on our function.
Now as a side point this might look familiar.
It's very similar to how jQuery works.
If we go to jQuery.com, Inspect Element and go to our Console.
We can type jQuery and we can see that jQuery is also a function.
However, if we type console.dir jQuery,
we can see we get this function with a bunch of stuff inside of it.
What this means is we can run jQuery like a function just like this,
or we can say jQuery.something.
Now the same goes for Knockout.
Our observable array, we can run it like this and
get the value or we can go ahead and say foo.,
and I'll say push(5).
When I push the number five into this array, it returns,
just like push normally does, the total length of the array.
And now if I run through, I can get back 1, 2, 3, 5, with four of them in there.
So in this way Knockout and jQuery work similarly.
Observables and
observable arrays are actually functions with keys on them as well.
Just like jQuery is a function with a bunch of keys and methods on it.
Now many people don't know this, and they use jQuery and
Knockout very successfully.
But it's wonderful to understand a bit more about what's actually going on
under the hood.